voici le résultat du scrutin majorité
requise pour l'adoption de la motion de
censure soit la majorité absolue des
membres composant l'Assemblée nationale
de 189 pour l'adoption 223 la majorité
requise n'étant pas atteinte la motion
de censure n'est pas adoptée je vais
maintenant mettre au voie la motion de
censure déposée par Madame Le Pen et 87
membres de l'Assemblée le scrutin est
annoncé dans l'enceinte de l'Assemblée
nationale je rappelle à nouveau que
seuls les députés favorables à la motion
de censure participent au scrutin et que
le vote se déroule dans les salles
voisine de l'hémicycle le scrutin va
être ouvert pour une durée de 20 minutes
il sera donc clos à
17h43 la séance est suspendue